Billy eilish seemingly impure Bliss
[Music]
the 20 year old was snapped smooching
her rumored new boo
[Music]
th
check out Billy and Jesse looking very
cozy after date night in Los Angeles
we're all just doing our thing you know
what I'm saying and it's not the first
time the pair have been out and about
dude here's the thing bro eagle-eyed
fans spotted Billy and Jesse just last
week enjoying a meal at Crossroads
Kitchen in the LA area
Andrew axelband who was dining at the
restaurant at the time told E.T about
their Night Out quote it definitely
seemed like a date and they stayed there
for three hours he reveals that the two
had a pasta and throughout the mill
Billy quote touched the back of Jesse's
head for a long time
[Music]
Jesse quote kissed her on the cheek and
they both kissed on the lips
Andrew adds quote Billy looked very good
and they seemed comfortable and happy
together they didn't get up at all from
their table during the meal and were
focused on each other and looking at
each other's eyes the whole time I just
think it's like
if it's something you you feel just like
do that like and I don't know that
sounds like super basic but it literally
is but hey the sightings don't stop
there I don't even know Billy and Jesse
started festivities early at Universal
Studios Halloween Horror Nights yeah the
two can't seem to keep away from each
other
[Music]
but neither Billy nor Jesse have
confirmed their romance and Billy's
known for keeping her love life private
she was last linked with actor Matthew
Tyler vorse sparking dating rumors back
in April of 2021 but they ultimately
call things off a year later with
Matthew shutting down cheating rumors
while also confirming their split
I wish that
[Music]